[Music]
it's really special and uh yeah that the
episode is one of my favorites feels
good to be back don't be too twisted I
still run this [ __ ] you're an executive
producer you're an artist and you
directed your first episode of Empire
congratulations I heard that it's
actually kind of a surreal moment I
ended my episode four years to the day
that I booked him fired and what no one
really knows because I've never talked
about is that the morning that I went on
my very first audition I met with alfre
woodard who's like one of my godmothers
and she prayed with me before I went on
that audition so four years to the day I
was directing my last scenes on my
episode but it was also with out free
Twitter because she's joined to play
cookies mother my life is crazy man like
I go full circle yeah exactly when your
best friend directs you and put you in
the most your episode was a Wakonda
inspired episode and everybody to be as
natural as possible
Gaby picked out her fro you know what
I'm saying
it just was I'm wanting it to be as
natural of an episode as possible he's
really stepped into the role of being
the director and it would say something
really seriously and I would really have
to fight yelling something back like
just making fun of them because he's in
his authoritative position I walk away
from the camera I would turn back are
you getting my angle tell me about
Terrence Howard and taraji P Henson what
they say when they found out you were
directing that but so what was their
reaction they were so supportive
Terrence of course right off bat was
like I'm so proud of you brother I'm
gonna be there for you he's like a big
brother he's like an uncle to rise you
of course messes with me a little bit
cuz that's our relationship but she was
wonderful and supportive and it was
great how do you explainable this
violence you do what you have to do Oh
this episode did Justine specifically
directed is the start of a really really
big fight that the Lions will have to
face that's all that I can tease for now
but it's a jump off point my name is
Lucius life
[Music]
[Applause]